on passe au débat de ce club monsieur on
va parler de Gabriel Atal le bon élève
du gouvernement qui a imprimé sa marque
au ministère de l'Éducation nationale
interdiction des abayas lutte contre le
harcelllement scolaire restauration de
l'autorité à l'école les dossiers sont
nombreux pour le ministre avant d'en
parler avec vous retour sur la rentrée
chargée de Gabriel hatal avec Fabien
Réard Gabriel Atal au côté de Brigitte
Macron le 7 septembre à poissie ville
endeuillé par le suicide d'un lycéen de
15 ans le ministre de l'éducation
nationale promet un choc dans la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire au terme
d'une rentrée qui aura fait de lui la
star du gouvernement depuis sa prise de
fonction gabrielal occupe le terrain
tout azimute comme ici 24 heures à peine
après sa nomination au chevet des profs
et des familles dont l'école a été
détruite pendant les émeutes il y a une
dizaine d'établissements qui sont quasi
intégralement détruits la verrière en
fait partie tous les élèves auront une
solution de scolarisation pour la
rentrée une rentrée scolaire qui va
permettre à Gabri la T de monopoliser
l'espace médiatique en dégainant une
mesure controversée l'interdiction de
labaya à l'école notre école est testé
ces derniers mois nous le savons les
tenues religieuses comme les abayas ont
fait leur apparition dans certains
établissements parfois c'est fait même
plusieurs années que c'est le cas la
fermeté de la réponse de l'école est
mise à l'épreuve une position ferme sur
la laïcité comme pour éclipser les
autres problèmes qui minent l'école
critique les syndicats en déplacement à
la fin août gabrielal tente de les
amadouer en ventant la restauration de
l'autorité et la revalorisation des
salaires mais le ministre peine à faire
adhérer les profs au nouveau Pact
enseignant d'Emmanuel Macron qui leur
propose d'assumer des missions
supplémentaires pour l'instant les
syndicats sont contre il y a aussi des
enseignants qui vont souhaiter rejoindre
le PACT parce que la réalité c'est que
vous avez des enseignants qui
aujourd'hui font des heures
supplémentaires ils continueront à le
faire en étant mieux payé pour ça autre
raté la promesse de mettre un enseignant
devant chaque classe à la rentrée n'a
pas été tenu par manque d'effectifs
desquakqu qui n'empêche pas Gabriel Atal
plus jeune ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la 5e République d'avoir le
vent en poupe dans les
sondages évidemment gabrielal pierre
est-ce qu'il a réussi sa rentrer Gabriel
Atal pour vous
attention ah il est in contestablement
depuis depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron et
président de la République une des
révélations politiques de cette
génération macronienne macroniste est-ce
qu'il a réussi cette rentrée il a réussi
au sens où les tous les voyants tous les
projecteurs se sont tournés vers lui il
a fait preuve d'autorité il a il a
réussi à placer le curseur de cette
rentrée scolaire sur un sujet on pensait
pas réellement quand même contenu de ses
origines politiques qu'il irait sur le
terrain de de la BAA donc je sais pas
siil l'a réussi il l'a réussi sur un
plan médiatique sur un sur un coup de
com je dirais euh un coup de com et un
coup coup de politique au sens où il en
il a envoyé des signaux dans un moment
où il nécessa pourinterdiction de la B
c'est un coup de Come c'est un coup de
Come à la fois un coup de Come c'est qui
s'impose médiatiquement sur je fais un
choix qui va qui va détonner qui sur
lequel je ne suis pas attendu on
reviendra peut-être sur son origine sur
ses origine politique parce que je je
fais partie de ceux qui pensent que vous
faites allusion soyez plus clair
allusion à sa scolarité non non pas du
tout pas du tout ça
çaisteig origines politiques au sens qui
vient de la gauche mais je fais partie
de ceux qui pensent qu'il fait partie de
cette génération macroniste macronienne
avec a berger avec Olivier verrand où
ils ont une histoire politique mais
demain le Front national ou le
rassemblement national arriverait au
pouvoir ou la France insoumise arriver
au pouvoir ce sont des personnalités
politiques qui adapteraient leur
discours à ceux qui sont au pouvoir ils
ont unepus ID non ils ont pas de corpus
idéologiquec on peut pas arriver de la
gauche et aujourd'hui faire la Baill en
premier geste politique en arrivant au
ministère d'ation l'éducation nationale
Dominique j'im pas juste sur la rentrée
après on va revenir évidemment en détail
sur sur les dossiers mais est-ce que
pour vous il a réussi comme au tableau
noir il a évidemment réussi sa rentrée
par rapport à à son prédécesseur qui est
un homme de qualité quoi que quoi que
dit certain mais qui n'arrivait pas à se
glisser dans les habits de ministre de
l'éducation nationale don il a marqué
une vraie rupture avec Papen oui et puis
qui a en même temps mais ne revenons pas
sur le prédécesseur mais je pas
davantage mais qui en même temps se
cherchait enfin nétait pas très très
clair non il a réussi à rentrer il y a y
a il y a il y a de l'autorité il y a de
la laïcité
il y a la nécessité
d'être d'être
ferme en accompagnement des des des
personnels des des des maîtres des
professeurs et
des je flotte un peu parce que je
comprends pas je comprends pas ce
que non mais je comprends pas ce que
Pierre a voulu dire en disant que sur
laaba comp te tenu de ses origines
politiques et ce mais soyez plus clair
qu'est-ce que c'est parce que la gauche
être de gauche c'est non je dis juste
qu'il a pas de colonne vertébrale c'est
tout et que demain Mar pouir pouvoir il
saura trouver des points de convergence
avec l'un et l'autre vous lui faites un
procès d'intention on verra le la
politique c'est des valeurs auxquel
chacun se se réfère c'est des
convictions et c'est aussi une forme de
pragmatisme
bon moi je lancens pas mais pour le
moment il est à la hauteur il est très
jeune Dominique le ministère l'éducation
nationale c'est sans doute un des
ministères les plus je pense quand on
fait de la politique c'est sans doute un
des plus beaux ministères une plus belle
responsabilité mais c'est sans doute un
des plus difficile mais c'est aussi une
des plus belles responsabilités
s'occuper de la
jeunesse bah écoutez quand on connaît
aujourd'hui ce qu'est l'état de
l'éducation nationale quand on connaît
les inégalités scolaires quand on sait
précisément que l'école et le lieu de
reproduction des inégalités on fait pas
une rentrée scolaire sur sa première
rentrée scolaire sur un sujet aussi
important soit-il qui peut créer du
débat sur lequel on peut avoir des
désaccords mais sur sur 200 sur 200 on
va en parler de la B vous en parle on en
parle tout de suite il est ministè
ministre d'éducation nationale ce que je
dis c'est qu'il fait sa première rentrée
non pas sur la question des inégalités
scolaires ou sur le renouvellement des
inégalités sociales par l'école il fait
sa rentrée scolaire sur 200 cas sur
plusieurs milliers de jeunes j'avais cru
comprends mais j'avais un peu deviné bon
donc cette affaire cette affaire est
parfaitement artificielle et il a eu de
votre point de vue hein il a eu il a eu
non je suis pas du tout d'accordin et il
a eu il a eu tout à fait TS de s'engager
sur ce terrainl il fait pas que cela
mais moi je le je sur ce terrain là je
suis clair et n à titre personnel je
salue la décision qu'il a prise encore
faut-il qu'elle soit exécutée
apparemment apparemment c'est le cas
mais pourquoi il a eu tort de mettre sur
la table la question de la laité à
l'école Pierre c'est même
r par que la question de la laïité à
l'école pour
vous il est la tête d'une des plus
hautes administrations c'est une
administration qui sans doute a un des
plus gros budget je crois le deuxè
budget de l'État il fait sa rentrée sur
200 personnes sur 100 personnes qui sont
susceptibles de rentrer à l'école sur la
BAA alors qu'on a des milliers d'enfants
qui sont en situation d'andicap c'est
pas un peu plus large sur la question de
la laïcité pour vous on a des milliers
d'enfants qui ont fait qui n'ont pas pu
faire leur rentrée dans de bonnes
conditions parce qu'ils sont en
situation de handicap il y a combien
d'enfants aujourd'hui qui sont dans des
établissements scolaires qui sont
flottant où il y a de la pluie qui
rentre où il y a Desf voilà que je veux
dire il faut lire il faut entendre les
sociologues qui ont travaillé sur sur la
question d'éducation sociale sur la
question des inégalités mais aussi sur
la question de comment d'un d'un
territoire à l'autre il y a aussi des
problèmes de comprends que vous
je dis juste que la priorité d'un
politique c'est quand même de s'occuper
du plus grand nombre pas de focaliser
sur une partie des gens et en plus cette
partie des gens c'est comme par hasard
des musulmans
non ne comprends pas que vous hommes de
gauche he vous êtes d'accord jusque là
oui d'accord je ne comprends pas que
vous homme de gauche parce qu'il y a un
ensemble de problèmes d'une gravité très
grande qui quelqueis dans les racines
remonte parfois loin en arrière vous
vous tiquiez sur une décision qui a pour
obj à la fois de réaffirmer l'autorité
des des maîtres des professeurs et et
des et des éducateurs dans toutes les
écoles de France et et surtout et
d'abord de réaffirmer la nécessité de ce
de ce cette laïcité qui doit nous réunir
et non pas nous
diviser là vous êtes une naïveté pardon
parce
queé on est je vous rappelle sans doute
je revendique une part deé chez
moi dire quand même avoir en tête que il
fait sa rentrée politique sur un Grand
journal de 20h sur pour pas pas sa
rentrée que làdessus il fait il sait
très bien quand je dis que c'est un coup
politique c'est quand il fait sa rentrée
qu'il va à la télé en disant voilà il
faut interdire
la attendez mais il y a combien de
décisions qui sont prises qui ne passe
pas le mur du son médiatique il aurait
fait un décret et j'aurais j'aurais été
sans doute très très mécontent mais il
aurait fait un décret il aurait fait son
arrêté qui aurait été envoyé à
l'ensemble des recteurs sans doute ça
auraittiqué il y aurait pas eu cette
espèce de bombe médiatique de focalise
sur une
population mettez-vous à la place de ces
jeunes filles Dominique mettez-vous à la
place de ces jeunes filles mettez-vous à
la place de ces jeunes filles qu'est-ce
qu'elle
r intelluellement je vais le faire voilà
mais qu'est-ce qu'elle ressent ces
jeunes filles quand ell se disent on est
200 dans cette France et on est on est
on nous demande de de de de retirer un
vêtement qui en plus de ça n'est pas
revendié
commus d'où vient cet AB AZ entend
irruption de la BA en France qui qui est
à l'origine de ça pour quelle motivation
religieuse politique qui et qui pardon
je je l'exprime mal mais qui tire les
ficelles derrière vous avez entendu le
secrétaire général de l'ONU s'exprimer
hier vous l'avez entendu j'ai choisi de
ne pas l'entendre oui vous avez bien
fait parce que je pense que on a des leç
à à retenir et à entendre oui de l'ONU
oui où il explique effectivement
aujourd'hui dans le monde il y a des
endroits où on considère que les femmes
sont vêu de manière trop courte et V
manère trop longue laiss les femmes
choisir le le est tout à fait clair que
la laïcité à la française n'est pas
comprise notamment dans l'immense empire
anglo-saxon on vous mettra pas d'accord
sur ce sujet on a compris on va parler
d'un autre dossier auquel s'est attaqué
Gabriel Atal dossier qui a fait
irruption malheureusement dans
l'actualité c'est la question du
harcèlement scolaire un plan va être
présenté lundi prochain Mathias c'est un
problème que Gabriel Atal a décidé de
prendre unas le corp absolument Gabriel
àal mais aussi tout le gouvernement
puisque vous le disiez un plan contre le
harcèlement scolaire élaboré du côté de
matigon devrait être dévoilé le 25
septembre prochain c'est donc lundi
l'élément déclencheur on le sait c'est
le suicide de Nicolas 15 ans scolarisé à
poissie au début du mois de septembre et
comme si cela ne suffisait pas il y a
cette lettre révélée par nos confrères
de BFM TV un courrier rédigé par
l'académie de Versailles et adressé
quelques mois avant le drame aux parents
de la victime jugeant d'inacceptable
leurs propos concernant le harcèlement
subi par leur fils qui aurait remis en
cause l'attitude de l'équipe pédagogique
alors le rectorat a également pris le
soin de rappeler les risques pénaux
encourus en cas de de dénonciation
calomnieuse une lettre jugée choquante
par par Elisabeth B qualifiée de honte
par Gabriel hatal qui n'a pas tardé à
réagir face aux caméras regardez mon
rôle de ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est évidemment d'être au
côté de mes agents mais je le dis aussi
mon rôle ça n'est pas de défendre à tout
prix une institution c'est de défendre à
tout prix la protection de nos élèves et
de nos enfants et c'est comme ça que je
continuerai à avancer voilà gabrielal
qui a donc fait preuve de fermeté là il
a reçu les recteurs d'académie lundi
après-midi exigeant deux un véritable
électro choc à tous les niveaux le
nouveau ministre de l'Éducation il en a
également profité pour annoncer qu'il
lançait un audit auprès de tous les
rectorats en cas sur les cas de
harcèlement enregistrés l'an dernier
avec au bout il l'ASS sur un changement
de méthode pour mieux réagir face à ce
phénomène et des nouvelles méthodes qui
devraient ensuite être évalué chaque
année et Mathias quelles autres mesures
avaient été prises avant ça alors on
peut par exemple citer les décrets qui
ont qui sont passés cet été le premier
permettant le changement d'école d'un
élève responsable de harcèlement plutôt
que d'imposer ce changement à celui qui
en est victime une manière d'éviter un
peu la double peine pour l'élève ciblé
une autre mesure c'est la possibilité de
prendre des sanctions contre un élève
d'un établissement scolaire différent de
celui de l'élève victime ce qui permet
d'étendre notamment le champ d'action
aux auteurs de cyberhcèlement et puis si
on monte encore avant on retrouve aussi
le programme PHARE un plan global de
prévention et de traitement des
situations de harcèlement lancé en 2021
ou encore la création de numéro
d'urgence tel que le 3020 et le 3018
évidemment c'est c'est un sujet qui
s'est invité dans l'actualité pierre on
a entendu Gabriel Attal he mon rôle
c'est pas de défendre à tout prix
l'institution c'est de défendre à tout
prix les élèves est-ce que là-dessus
vous saluez l'action de Gabriel hatal
ces derniers jours je je je là-dessus je
pense qu'il y a pas de politique
politicienne je j'imagine qu'il est même
s'il y a des désaccords il est un
ministre engagé à faire en sorte que la
question du harcèlement soit un problème
qui soit pas réglé parce qu'on réglera
jamais le problème mais en tout cas
qu'il y ait des mesures qui soient
prises et qui soient des mesures
efficace on vient de comprendre à
travers un certain nombre d'enquêtes
d'ailleurs de journalistes que
aujourd'hui c'était pas que la question
des élèves mais c'était aussi la
question de la chaîne de du
institutionnel c'est-à-dire que une
famille pouvait avoir alerté
l'institution le rectorat du cas de son
enfant d'un problème de harcèlement
c'était la famille derrière qui devenait
parfois même souvent suspecte d'être
mauvaise éduc enfin qu'elle était dans
qu'elle avait sans doute un comportement
mauvais vis-à-vis de son enfant qui se
retrouvait dans des situations isolées
donc du coup ils envoyé les services
sociaux contrôler les familles qui
étaient qui avaient fait des des alertes
donc estce que du coup il met un coup de
pied dans la four milire ab làdus alors
oui sans doute j'ai vu qu'il avait reçu
alors là aussi bon c'est sans doute
c'est utile il a reçu l'ensemble des
recteurs pour leur leur dire avec
fermeté qu'il allait mener le combat de
manière très virulente et qui comptait
sur ses recteurs pour mener cette
bataille très bien le Yaka fokon ça
marche pas mais je dis pas ça pour
gabrielal je dis ça pour tout le monde
et compris ceux qui vont critiquer
Gabriel Atal et qui vont dire nous on a
la meilleure des solutions non je pense
que là pour la peine il faut que
l'ensemble des des de la communauté
éducative se saisisse ce sujet et
parviennent à à à à faire en sorte que
ce système parce que c'est un système
soit remis en cause et que la parole des
enfants la parole des familles soit
davantage davantage prise en compte vous
savez c'est c'est un sujet qui traverse
la société on l'a vu avec le mouvement
Mitou on le voit avec le mouvement sur
la question de l'inceste la parole des
personnes concernées doit être davantage
entendu par la justice mais aussi là en
l'occurrence à l'école par le système
institutionnel scolaire est-ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin il y a notamment un
je de dire voilà le pierrejcquesemain
que nous
aimons pres que consensuel c'est ça je
je
avec une
formulation au second degré mais quand
même mais quand même certains à à droite
et au rassemblement national disent il
faut sortir les élèves harceleurs du
système scolaire il faut les mettre dans
des établissements spécialisés oui
toujours plus toujours plus dans dans
l'outrance je trouve déjà euh
intéressant d'abord que un un tabou
tombe je n'oublie pas le rôle des
associations depuis quelques années sur
ce terrain du harcèlement elle nétait
elle n'avait pas toujours les relais
qu'il fallait elle n'était pas toujours
prise au sérieux comme comme comme ça
aurait été souhaitable et donc
maintenant ce tabou du harcèlement euh
tombe je veux vous dire je me demande
depuis des dizaines d'années de depuis
longtemps combien de victimes le
harcèlement non combattu a fait j'ai
j'ai peur que bon voyons ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui le tabou tombe
euh le le rassemblement national que
vous évoquez c'est toujours plus pardon
mais ce sujet n'incite pas à la à la
polémique mais toujours plus dans
l'outrant ça veut dire ça veut dire
c'est je trouve déjà très bien je trouve
très bien j'enlève le déjà je trouve
très bien que la décision qui a été
prise que ce soit le harceleur quand il
est dûement repéré et cetera qui soit
invité à changer d'établissement et non
pas le harceler déjà on est dans un
changement qualitatif mais on en est là
on en est là il faut il faut il faut de
toute façon faire toujours attention que
évidemment à à la victime présumée et à
l'agress présumé parce que j'entendais
d'une oreille un peu distraite ce matin
en me réveillant à la radio justement un
cas qui me paraît là pour la peine
extrêmement extrêmement extrême là pour
la peine d'un élève qui aurait été
récupéré par la police en salle de
classe menoté en salle de classe ramené
au commissariat pour avoir été un
agresseur potentiel d'un autre élève de
son de son étaissement bah je je sais
pas si c'est les bonnes méthodes
c'està-dire que à minima il faut quand
même que l'enfant soit pris en charge
par la communauté éducative et peut-être
derrière qu'il y ait une procédure mais
enfin aller chercher un élève
l'intitution scolaire doit rester quand
même une institution scolaire la police
n'a rien à y faire pierre j'ai entendu
ça des deux oreilles et j'ai
j'ai j'ai non vous l'avez entendu d'une
oreille bon moi de deux j'ai quand même
sursauté évidemment dans l'absolu c'est
pas souhaitable que des policiers
arrivent dans le couloir à côté de la
class j'imagine avec le feu vert du du
du proviseur ou du chef d'établissement
plutôt euh pour pour demander à un élève
de quitter la classe et de partir il est
partit en guarde à vue mais je je peux
pas imaginer que ce soit pas pour une
situation d'une gravité établie et très
très grande et après j'arrête parce que
j'ai pas spéculer qu'est-ce qui se
serait passé s'ils avaient attendu la
sortie de la classe que les autres qu'il
avaient crié que ceci cela au point où
nous en sommes aujourd'hui je préfère la
police qui intervient interpelle et
demande des comptes à un jeune homme qui
aurait gravement fauté à un suicide de
plus un dernier mot sur Gabriel
hatal mais pas avec vous Maas pardon
pouroi je vous regarde avec Pierre et
Dominique gabrielal est-ce que
l'éducation nationale est un trempelin
pour gabrielal on va regarder juste ce
sondage d'Aris interactif de l'Institut
sondage Haris interactif qui a testé
différentes hypothèses pour la
présidentielle et qui a donc testé une
candidature de Gabriel Atal alors
Gabriel Atal il fait moins bien
qu'Édouard Philippe que Bruno Le Maire
ou que Gérald haranin mais il ferait
mieux que François Baayou Elisabeth bne
ou Jean Castex Pier oui je je l'ai dit
je c'est une révélation politique il est
très politique là où on a attendu
beaucoup des ministres de d'Emmanuel
Macron de faire de la politique Gabriel
Atal avec Aurore berger un peu Olivier
verrant a été de ceux qui ont donné un
peu de de de substance politique
justement à ce quiétait la macronie donc
oui il fait partie sans doute des
figures montantes maintenant il faut
qu'il ait un bilan avant d'être
présidentiable mais c'est vrai que sur
le ministère de l'Éducation nationale il
joue sa crédibilité ça c'est certain
Dominique ce sondage me me fait
sourireanl méenchon FO sur c'est pas ça
c'est pas c'est pas ça pierre c'est
c'est que je trouve déjà le score qui
lui est qui lui est accordé pour une
présidentielle à l'âge qu'il a alors
qu'il vient d'être nommé et et il fait
des début spectaculaire et
impressionnant il vient tout juste
d'être nommé ministre d'éducation
nationale on est déjà en train
d'imaginer qu'il puisse devenir
président de la République en 2027 alors
moi je prends tous les paris il a a
priori a priori un grand avenir
politique il ne sera évidemment pas
candidat pour vous c'est évident pardon
pour vous c'est évident bah il faut
prendre des risques vous les avvez dit
qu'il fallait Pr j'en prends j'en prends
évid' était malin comme son nom circule
pour la mairie de Paris je pense que ça
serait une étape beaucoup plus favorable
pour lui pour faire oublier de ce qu' a
sil est un jour Premier ministre ce sera
très bien mais attendez on s'emb
balle suffit de pas on peut pas on peut
ne jamais avoir été un élu local et
devenir président de la République il
para absolument c'est
l'exemple venu de on p parler de
l'avenir de Gabriel à oui oui il a un
grand avenir mais ne l'installez pas à
l'Élysée en 2027 quand même ah n rien
bon
sens